on va commencer ces insolites par la
découverte d'une profession mais cette
profession on la connaissait déjà un peu
grâce à Gainsbourg et Jane Birkin
c'est
un faiseur de plaisanterie qui dit
toujours à quoi bon à quoi bon
un aquaboniste un peu trop idéaliste qui
répète sur tous les tout à quoi bon
[Musique]
profession à quoi boniste dans c'est pas
ça je crois que j'ai mal articulé c'est
à quoi bonniste avec un peu comme
poisson voilà je vous ai enduit je suis
navré aquaponie et pas à quoi bony c'est
toute la différence c'est dans le dans
le pays mais alors en quoi ça consiste
on parle pas de poney ici parce que moi
ça m'a fait penser à l'aquaponie je sais
pas du tout ça d'accord non non en fait
c'est un monsieur qui s'appelle Richard
dispmer qui a monté sa ferme la ferme de
Richard dans les Yvelines à
Saint-Nom-la-Bretèche voilà et c'est un
mode de culture qui permet d'économiser
énormément d'eau justement on en parlait
tout à l'heure de ce problème de
sécheresse lui avec son maraîchage il
utilise 90% d'eau en moins que le
maraîchage traditionnel alors comment
fait-il il a des bassins avec à
l'intérieur des poissons lui il a des
esturgeons et détruite arc-en-ciel qui
sont des poissons qui plaisent au goût
parce que en mars il va les vendre aussi
voilà alors boissons évolue dans leur
dans leur bassin bien tranquillement et
cette eau est chargée donc en nutriments
je vous fais pas de dessin et cette eau
très riche va aller nourrir
une culture hors sol une culture
maraîchère alors lui il dit qu'il est
une micro ferme à en aquaponie ou
aquaponique c'est une micro ferme par
rapport aux fermes de maraîchage
traditionnel lui il a une taille tout à
fait correcte pour une ferme en
aquaponie il a 1000 m² et alors ce qui
est assez rigolo c'est que ce monsieur
il a été 17 ans dans l'entreprise c'est
un ingénieur informatique a pris la fée
je crois du contrôle de gestion il a été
financier enfin que des métiers comme ça
et puis tout d'un coup ben je peux en
avoir ras-le-bol complètement et il a
cherché un projet de métier qui
correspondait plus à ses valeurs un
métier qui est du sens et un jour par
hasard il est tombé sur un reportage sur
Arte donc sur une ferme aquaponique
bref vous avez compris et donc qu'est-ce
qui cultive et cultive pas mal en ce
moment bah ça dépend des session bien
sûr là en ce moment il y a pas mal de
légumes à feuilles il y a il va y avoir
du chou chinois il y a pas mal de
salades du mesclin de la Roquette de la
feuille de moutarde
chou chinois je l'ai dit à dit pas mal
d'herba aromatiques aussi alors soit on
vient acheter les légumes sur place à ça
dans la Bretèche la ferme de Richard
soit on commande sur son site il voulait
RA avec un véhicule propre électrique
soit il a des revendeurs voilà qu'est-ce
que j'ai pu oublier sur cette
chaussette culture mais en tout cas
c'est très intéressant
parler du confinement peut-être que ça
ça a joué non
beauté je vois partir à présent dans la
forêt de Rambouillet dans laquelle on
peut rencontrer bien sûr des chasseurs
mais aussi un des des chevaux des des
cavaliers des serres des biches des
chevreuils en plein plein d'animaux on
peut aussi handicap il apercevoir du
côté de l'espace renvoyé des aigles et
des hiboux mais Véronique je rassure
noter les spectateurs on ne voyait pas
pris vous n'avez pas pris de substance
illicine vous le jurez pourtant
extrêmement on peut y apercevoir aussi
des kangourous ça paraît incroyable
comme ça mais c'est la vérité vraie
imaginez-vous que dans les années 70 un
directeur du zoo de Bâle a offert cette
kangourous un de ses amis qui avait un
petit parc zoologique à émoncer donc
Yvelines près de Rambouillet près de la
forêt et puis alors c'est marsupiaux se
sont bien plus et sont reproduits et
puis vous savez le principe du kangourou
ça saute on va total ils sont un petit
peu échappé dans la forêt d'à côté et
puis il y a eu les tempêtes qui ont dû à
base des clôtures enfin je ne sais quoi
bref ils ont un peu fichier le corps
dans la forêt de Rambouillet où je
trouve très bien parce que ce sont des
Walibi si vous vouliez savoir des Walibi
de Bennett King de sorte de kangourous
qui viennent ils sont originaires de
Tasmanie et la Tasmanie et Rambouillet
c'est le même climat donc ils sont les
plus heureux des kangourous là-bas ils
mangent comme on les serres comme les
chevreuils mais bon ils ont un peu rien
à faire là quoi alors ne soyez pas déçus
Grégory si vous y allez en pleine
journée vous risquez pas d'en voir
vraiment parce que ce sont des animaux
nocturnes alors au cas où je voulais
décrire donc ils ont un peu moins d'un
mètre les bras levés gris roux
et puis et puis donc il se promène la
nuit donc il y a malheureusement des
collisions et des voitures parce que je
sais pas si vous avez remarqué mais un
animal quand il y a des disciples
traversées qui une voiture ou pas il y
va bon bref et alors ce qui est aussi
pour la petite anecdote c'est que les
assurances ont le droit de faire des
attestations comme quoi il existe des
des kangourous c'est le seul endroit de
le seul ville de France on peut attester
d'un d'un accident avec un kangourou il
y a quand même eu quelqu'un qui en a vu
un camping de Saint-Arnoult quelqu'un
d'autre un habitant qui en a vu un dans
son jardin à habiller alors tout ça je
le sais quelques témoignages non mais
bien sûr oui non c'est pas une vue de
l'esprit bien il y en a vraiment mais
c'est des accidents malheureusement qui
permettent de de prouver qu'il y en a et
bah ça c'est François feuilloux qu'il
raconte dans les cours républicains
voilà toutes ces petites histoires de
kangourous ce qui est insolite c'est
aussi qu'ils aient réussi à s'acclimater
à ils sont très bien
alors il s'est un peu un vide juridique
parce qu'ils sont ni nuisibles ni
chassables enfin c'est un peu comme les
perruches vertes d'Afghanistan
intéressant
la semaine prochaine pour d'autres
insolit